[Musique]
il y avait treize mille délinquants en
aujourd'hui il y à la 36 milles s'il est
souvent question de cette alarmante
aggravation on parle surtout des méfaits
et des délits commis par les jeunes
voyous et rarement des mesures qui sont
prises pour les rééduquer c'est pourquoi
nous interrogeons tout ce que fait t'on
en france pour mettre les jeunes sur le
bon chemin
c'est à cette question que nous nous
efforçons de répondre aujourd'hui
torse allure suspecte chez souvent sur
la déviation la de longjumeau
emma ici ceux de vauban 41 bien reçu nur
adan sur place
[Musique]
lorsqu'un jeune a commis un délit il est
affecté et a mené au dépôt il est
ensuite conduit devant un juge pour
enfants
c'est au juge que revient la tâche de
décider du sort du jeune délinquant
monsieur le juge
supposons que vous êtes en présence d'un
jeune qui vient de commettre un délit
que faites vous madame j'ai quelques
solutions ma disposition la première
c'est de le remettre à sa famille la
seconde de le placer en sont
d'observation et la troisième la plus
rare de le placer sous mandat de dépôt
en maison d'arrêt je ne pourrais prendre
ces mesures immédiates que lorsque je me
serais renseigner et le premier
interlocuteur est alors la madame je
vous ai face c'est le jeune qui est là
aussitôt je lui pose des questions sur
ce qu'il a fait et ce qui est la cause
de son arrestation et je lui pose des
questions sur ce qu'il est sur ce qu'est
sa famille sur ce qu'il a fait comme
enseignement professionnel comme métier
et ayant eu ce cette information je la
complète éventuellement peu parce que
maudiront les parents nous sommes au
centre d'observation de savigny sur orge
il est 7 heures ce soir comme tous les
soirs une camionnette arrive du dépôt
avec sa cargaison d'adolescents déroutés
[Musique]
bon écoute tu vas me donner ce que tu es
gentil tu es tu n'as pas d'argent aux
bijoux ni rien des objets de valeur bon
ben je te remercie il va rester quelques
temps à l'accueil et à prendre contact
avec capteur d'abord immédiatement après
leur inscription c'est le premier
contact avec l'éducateur au bout de deux
mois et demi ou en avril un rapport au
juge
c'est pour ça qu'il nous a placés ici
parce que c'est pas le peu de temps
qu'il a va se poser est passé dans son
bureau qu'il a eu le temps de vous
connaître connaître tout ce que vous
pouvez faire c'est pour ça qu'ils vous
place ici alors on enlève dans un
rapport au juge en expliquant ce sera
tout détailler vos possibilités vos
aptitudes et lui à ce moment-là prendra
une décision
c'est pour ça après cette première prise
de contact nous allons interroger ces
jeunes nous avons voulu savoir comment
il en était arrivé là
qu'est ce que j'ai fait mais moi j'ai
par ailleurs
en quoi la perrière à pepsi cola des
bouteilles de coca cola plusieurs fois
le monde c'est la première fois pourquoi
pas envie que j'avais de l'argent on
vous donne pas d'argent de poche y
allons lui simon notamment d'amener ce
proche colligeant dont dany feuillage
travail vous êtes bien je ne suis pas un
peu quand elle est vue comme une
araignée ou n'a pas classé
on a un peu poussé pas qui m'a parlé
comme à tous les papas qui sera bien ils
ont tous entre ces deux one initier des
jeunes où habitait dans un appartement
vous qu'avez vous fait on sait en voit
une fille 4 quand même et il y en a deux
qui n'ont rien fait et la constante et à
le faire qu elle voulait bien la fel
voulait bien passé avec tout le monde
il y avait sept garçons elle voulait
bien passé avec tout le monde mais sauf
avec jean on l'a fait quand même bien le
porter plainte
qu'avez-vous moi j'ai 15 ans et demi et
16 ans et vous 17 ans et demi et quel
effet cela vous fait d'être ici je me
sens affirmé
je veux personne sur tous mes copains je
m'ennuie monsieur le directeur est
plutôt est ce qu'il ya des barreaux ici
comme vous avez pu le constater ce n'est
absolument pas une prison il n'y a pas
de barreaux et même un grand espace des
terrains verts terrains de sport etc
combien de jeunes avec louise 190 en
arrive tous les jours tous les joueurs 2
ou 3 3 ou 4 cela dépend de nos départs
et bien nous conservons les garçons en
moyenne trois mois et au cours de ces
trois mois avec différentes sortes
d'examens d'observation directe
d'observation par des spécialistes
nous essayons de dresser un bilan de
personnalité le garçon est de présenter
ce bilan aux magistrats pour qu'ils
puissent prendre sa décision
être en observation qu'est ce que cela
veut dire
cela veut dire qu'à travers les
activités d'apparence normale
l'école l'atelier le sport on va essayer
de comprendre les raisons qui ont fait
que ces garçons ne sont pas des garçons
comme les autres toi moi pour comprendre
trois mois pour savoir pourquoi toi moi
qui vont peut-être changer toute une vie
à réty sais pas ce que vous avez fait
des bêtises qu'elle soit votée
je suis parti de chez moi et après
j'avais fait des bêtises
non c'est tout oui mais pas volé sur
qu'est-ce que vous avez volé un vélo
c'est tout
non ou encore leur j'en attends quel âge
avez-vous présent kiki responsable de la
bêtise que vous avez commises
ma belle-mère votre belle-mère comment
ça toujours à me taper et je suis parti
de chez moi j'avais des frères des
soeurs s'est elle tapait les frères et
les soeurs aussi au nom est appris que
mon frère
pour faire votre frère et vous oui est
ce que vous savez pourquoi parce qu'on
était passé d'enfant
toutes ces confidences
on ne doit pas les arracher aux enfants
il faut qu'elles viennent d'elles-mêmes
au hasard d'une rencontre dans un
couloir le soir une fois le travail
terminé chaque détail de la vie passée
peut-être une information précieuse pour
l'éducateur c'est pourtant com de com du
monde et dans c'est trop dur que c'était
comme un caméléon
demain tu as ton permis dès que tu as
pensé à l'accident arrive tout cela pour
gérer qu'un truc con dios et tout le
reste c'est tout tu n'a pensé à rien à
ce moment là je réfléchis un peu comment
ça s'est passé
tu te crois que je salue de sources très
bien dit mais c'est une canule s'ouvrait
facilement et une môme sur certains
volets oui je veux ni moi c'était ça se
passait à quel endroit de la villeneuve
la garenne après écoute et où loeb c'est
un bouton de marche monter dedans
pourrait faire un tour et après demain
matin je la reprise est-ce que c'est ton
amour de la mécanique qui t'a conduit à
vendre une voiture oui un peu c'est tout
le monde il le désire conduire le désir
comme tu n'as pas de mobylette
c'est une conciliation si souvent avec
mon verre ressources d'où il se consacre
alors je comprend principalement ainsi
par ailleurs du conduit de dans un grand
site en est totalement privée
oui ouais d'accord c'est le fait de 2,2
comment dirais-je de conduire seule une
voiture sans singer
tout seul compromettre dans la voiture
pour être ton propre maître dans la voix
dire je trouve pas ce que je voulais en
trois mois les éducateurs ont le temps
de devenir des confidents et des amis
nous avons eu la chance de se plaindre
la joie immense d'un enfant qui vient
d'apprendre sa prochaine libération et
qu'il annonce à son éducateur
surtout que je suis à paris alors je
suis chez moi je pense je prends le
métro c'est une fille chez moi comment
comment tu te sens là je me sens bien si
tous les foyers discours et ce matin je
parle comme si michel huys avenir
pourrait se dire moi elle est arrivée ce
matin à net rebond ce matin
car ce monsieur dit personne ici sauf le
directeur du médiateur dans le pays
je suis pour dormir ni prochain puis
qu'une semaine à patienter
t'es bonne attention à ce qu on
tambourine
comment tu vois ça les perturbe
semi-liberté les troyens ont match a
expliqué moins fidèle d'abord commencé
par travailler
elle met un peu d'argent de côté acheter
ce que j'ai besoin
sordo soit faire de bêtises moi monsieur
s'est terminée des conneries en terminer
[Musique]
je peux je peux m'amuser mais sans
déconner j'ai trouvé de commun enfin tu
libéré je me tiens bénard se passait pas
je bosse ça sera déjà une bonne chose de
faite mercredi prochain 7 400 toit noir
l'emmènera vers paris c'est peut-être là
que le plus dur l'attend est il vraiment
débarrasser de ce mal figurants que l'on
nomme délinquance juvénile
[Musique]